The difference between
an invention and innovation,
is that invention is something new.
Innovation is making something
real and economic out of this invention.
Shai Albaranes,
thank you for coming
to 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Thank you very much for having me.
I'm fine, thank you.
Wonderful.
I'm extremely excited to have you.
Talking about corporate innovation.
You're part of a group called Orbia,
22,000 people,
yet you're tasked with possibly
one of the most difficult jobs there.
How do you take an organization
of tens of thousands of people,
and bring innovation,
whether it's bottom up, top down?
I had the privilege of being both
at large organizations like 8200,
which is a large organization,
but also part of a startup
like Hippo, with just 200 people.
But Shai, before that,
you have to tell me how you started
by creating a board game.
What's that about?
Okay.
So, it was after my army service.
And during the Army service
you feel empowered, you feel important
and you feel great.
And then you finished your army service.
I was in a combat unit.
And basically, no one recognizes you
for whatever you did.
So, when you look for a job,
you start getting all kind
of like lousy jobs.
So, I started one of these lousy jobs
and I was pretty bored.
And it happened that it was
the 50th anniversary of Israel.
And a friend of mine and I,
we said, this must be
a very, very good business opportunity.
So, we started thinking,
what how can we make a business
out of this big event
in the history of Israel,
50 years of Israel.
And to make a long story short,
we screened a few ideas,
but we came up with this idea
that people don't know
or kids do not know
the history of Israel.
If we can teach them
in a very fun way,
the basics about the history of Israel,
the leader of the peace agreement,
the war, or the sporting events,
that will be great.
So, this is what we did.
I have to say that I love that.
I love that because
like a lot of other kids,
I grew up not really learning
the history of Israel.
When I was about to go to
the Officers Academy to [--],
I got a book that was this thick
that I had to now
within about 24 hours,
memorized the whole thing.
And I wish I had a game like that
when I was just starting out.
But walk me through
your journey from there,
because you've done quite a few
fascinating things leading up
to corporate innovation.
A lot of them are really tangled.
You have McKinsey in there,
you have Netafim in there.
Talk to me a little bit about,
about your process up to today.
Yes.
So, I think the funny thing is that
now looking 20 years back,
there is kind of like a line,
a thread connecting all these things.
But when I was doing each one of these,
it didn't seem like there is a story.
So, as I said,
my first real business experience
was this startup company
that developed the board game
for the kids.
And then I said, okay,
I need to get a technology education.
So, I went to do
a computer science degree in the IDC.
And I was very, very fortunate
to be accepted
to the Zell program in the IDC.
Yeah.
And this was the first year
of the Zell program, right?
The very first year?
So, you were in it with Assaf?
Yes.
This is how I know Assaf very well.
This is how you know Assaf, my boss.
Amazing. Okay.
Exactly. Exactly.
And we were actually
in a very small study group
where we did a consulting project
to a big company in Israel.
We became good friends.
And yeah, this is how I know Assaf.
Now things are coming together.
He also went to McKinsey.
Okay. Great. Wonderful.
Yeah.
So, what happens after Zell?
So, I did Zell.
And what I understood
that I love technology,
but I like the business side
of technology.
I couldn't program like it was,
I got bored.
So, then I worked
for a few startup companies,
mainly in business development
and marketing.
So, you could say that the first,
you know, 8, 9 years were kind of like
an entrepreneurial type of experience.
I do my own start up
or other people start ups.
And then in 2007,
I said, okay, I want to jump
to the adult pool,
you know, the big boys pool.
And by the way, that's another,
maybe Assaf even doesn't know about it,
but when we were in Zell,
he was starting to talk
about doing an MBA
in Stanford and in Chicago.
And I said, "Really?"
It never even crossed my mind.
But then I said, okay,
if he talks about it, it makes sense.
Let me dig into that.
So, I dug into that a few years later
and I understood that I want to do it
and I can do it.
So, I went to do my MBA at INSEAD,
which was a great experience.
And then I said, okay,
this was nice.
But the real business school
of the world is consulting.
So, I joined McKinsey.
And I did that for a few years
in London and in Israel.
Wow.
And then in 2012,
there was a very interesting opportunity
to join Netafim.
Netafim is an Israeli born company
and today's the largest
irrigation company in the world.
Probably some people know about it.
In the world?
I had no idea.
I knew it was a miracle.
It's one of Israel's early miracles,
but I wasn't aware
that it's the biggest irrigation company
in the world.
It is.
It's now more than billion dollars
in revenue.
And it's the largest irrigation company
in the world. Yeah.
Wow.
And do you mind sharing just in two words
the back story of Netafim?
Why it was innovation through necessity?
Because I get so inspired
every time I understand that
why it even happened.
It happened, again, like you said,
out of necessity.
So, people were looking
to grow stuff in the desert.
In the desert.
Because we had to.
Yeah.
Because you know,
a big chunk of Israel land
is a desert.
And people were sent
to inhabit to the desert.
So, the Netafim were founded
by one of the kibbutz in Israel,
Kibbutz Hatzerim.
Because they needed a way
to cultivate the desert
and they needed a job for the elderly
that couldn't go work outside.
But they needed to do something indoor.
Right?
So, they partner with an engineer
who came up with the
original drip concept,
and they launched Netafim.
And, you know,
60 something years later,
it is the largest
irrigation company in the world.
It's remarkable to me
to think that we have an Israeli company
that is 60 something years old.
But you're in Netafim,
you're working there really
with the leadership.
How do you get enticed
by this idea of innovation?
Because already Netafim
is a big organization,
but then you also transition to Orbia
and there you are literally,
you're tasked with leading innovation.
So, how does that come about?
Okay.
So, just to close the story,
Netafim, I did various positions,
the last one I was managing
the company product portfolio.
So, we were constantly thinking,
what is it that we can innovate.
Right?
Right.
A billion dollar portfolio. Right?
Yes. Yes.
And then, you know,
for me, it was a big,
a combination of a couple of things
in early 2018
when Orbia acquired Netafim.
And Orbia is a very large public company.
A multinational seven billion dollars
in revenues.
So, they acquired Netafim in 2018.
And the other thing that happened
in the same very month,
a new CEO came to Orbia.
A guy called Daniel Martinez,
and he started a very, very
ambitious transformation program.
And he knew that innovation
is a significant pillar
of that transformation.
So, he was looking for someone
to lead the innovation activities
in inside Orbia.
So, he pulled me out of Netafim
and put me as part of the
Orbia management team and told me,
"Corporate innovation. Go build it."
So, before we continue to talk about
exactly what you did there,
when I hear the word innovation,
a lot of people today
to hear innovation,
it's a little bit of a fluffy word.
Yes, we innovate this.
It's like a when a startup says
we revolutionize this. Right?
What is innovation in its core
that this new CEO said,
I need a figure that can come in
and help us do it properly, within Orbia?
Right.
So, there are multiple dimensions
to that answer.
I'll walk you like briefly,
let me know if you want me
to dig into any one of these.
Okay?
Wonderful.
So, the first thing was to define,
what is innovation, right?
For us, because innovation in a startup
is completely different than innovation
in a large multinational.
Right?
And I spend maybe the first six months
doing a lot of research.
But what does it mean,
innovation in the corporate world?
And I met startups
and VCs and incubators
and accelerators and academia
and I read thousands of books
and articles and in order
to be able to clarify
what is it we want to do. Right?
So, the first thing was a
relatively simple definition
that everybody will understand.
It doesn't mean that it's perfect,
but something that
everybody can connect to.
So, internally, we define innovation
as creating something new
that addresses a need.
And, this is the important part,
the economic value that it will generate
is higher than the cost
of developing it. Right?
Why is that important?
Why is that an important piece
of the puzzle?
It's an important piece because
you might know that 95 or so percent
of the global IP or patents
that are being created
are never commercialized.
Right?
95%?
Yeah.
So, the difference between
an invention and innovation
is that invention is something new.
Innovation is making something real
and economic out of this invention.
Right?
I've never thought of it that way.
So, the innovation
is different than creativity.
It's different than invention.
Because, as we said,
95% of the invention
are never commercialized.
Not because they're not novel,
but because there's no economic value.
Right?
So, this is how we define it.
And then, the second step was
to understand that innovation
Is actually not a single term
and there are different types
of innovation.
Right?
Your audience can read about it.
But I'll give you
just the one sentence.
There are multiple frameworks
to think about
the types of innovation.
But the classic one
that people usually use
is the difference between
core, adjacent,
and transformative innovation.
And we don't need to spend more
a lot of time on that.
But just to understand that there are
different levels of complexity
in innovation
There are some things that are closer
to your current capabilities, the core.
And there are innovation
that relates to new capabilities,
new customers, new markets
that you want to develop,
and this is more transformative.
Anything in between.
And it is critical
as an organization, not a startup,
a startup can focus
on one specific innovation.
Right?
But as a corporate,
you need to invest in all
of these three dimensions.
Right?
Right.
It's an important understanding.
So, this was a realization
number two. Okay?
Realization number three
was about the fact
that innovation, again,
in the context of a corporate world
is not an activity, it's a portfolio.
So, if you think about, you know,
you're an angel investor, right?
If you invest in one company,
you have 90% chances to fail.
But if you invest in 30,
you have a certain probability
that you can out of the entire portfolio,
will make a profit, right?
Right.
And this is exactly the same way
to think about innovation.
It's a portfolio of activities.
Some of them will fail,
some of them will succeed.
But you want to think about
the entire portfolio
and that it progresses towards
the goals that you want to achieve.
So, this was realization number three.
And realization number four
is about the time horizon.
You want to invest in activities
in that portfolio.
Some of them are short term.
Some of them are medium term.
And some of them
will pay out 7, 10 years out.
This is if you want
to kind of like the thing
that I understood in the research,
like the four principles, if you wish,
this is what I understood
in the research.
And in the past two years
were trying to implement all of that
and building the processes,
the infrastructure,
the management and all of that.
Which, by the way,
that's another important thing.
Many people think about innovation
is kind of like a project, an initiative,
but it's important to understand
that if you really want
to be successful in innovation,
you have to think about it
as a corporate function.
Like finance, like marketing,
like IT, like R&D.
You know, you have processes,
you have ton of development,
you have succession plans,
you have budget,
you have annual targets.
You know, it's a corporate function
like any other function.
If you don't manage it this way,
it will never succeed.
Right.
Now, I'm particularly interested
in what you were saying before
about the innovation,
really to manage innovation,
you're not managing a single project
because you will never invest
in a single company and say,
I'm putting all my eggs in this basket.
You manage a portfolio
of innovative solutions
that most of them will fail,
but you expect that of the whole basket,
you'll see some profit
or some greatness for the company.
And I keep thinking
to all these occurrences where
I'm hearing about my friends
who may be going
to their managers or their bosses
and suggesting some innovative project.
And the answer is always no,
because this is
not likely to succeed.
But I can't help but wonder
whether their managers
are thinking strategically about,
okay, what if we just take a pool
of these innovative projects,
if we can allow ourselves to.
And then allow for
the real innovation to happen.
But Shai, how do you actually tangibly
go into an organization
that is 22,000 people
and encourage innovation?
Because I'm guessing
that you're not hiring people
to just do innovative things.
You're trying to encourage innovation
internally within
the core of the company.
Right?
Yeah.
So, I think, what I'll share with you
are the six current programs
that we have under the umbrella
of corporate innovation,
and this will make it
a little bit clearer.
Okay?
First and foremost,
before we talk about the six programs,
if the CEO and the senior leadership
do not think it's a top priority,
it will never succeed.
And I'm fortunate
to have a very, very
visionary, future thinking
and also a very, very humble
and truly great person as my CEO.
Right?
Without that, I could never embark
on the journey.
And also the entire management of Orbia,
which, by the way,
all of them other than one
are new since the last two years.
Right?
And really international,
but within the corporate innovation,
so, we have six programs.
One, we have Orbia Ventures,
which is the corporate
venture capital fund of Orbia.
With $130M that we invest
in startups that are strategic
to anyone of our five businesses.
Then we have
a startup partnership program
where we want to take,
products or services developed
by startup companies
and expand our offering
through a commercial partnership.
We have an advanced analytic program,
which we started three months ago,
to deploy advanced technologies
like AI machine learning
into the activity that we do.
We have a program
called, Orbia Lighthouse.
This is actually, the official definition
is a Venture Studio.
Again, it's a new term in innovation.
People can dig it up.
But Innovation Studio is kind of like
an internal incubator.
Like we launch new digital ventures
or new startups.
But everything is managed internally.
The budget, the exploration,
the EIR recruiting,
everything is internal.
The 5th program
is what we call Launchpad,
it's an internal innovation program
where every person in the organization
can participate in innovation.
And how do we coach them
and how do we train them
and how we give them budget to pilot.
And we only have eight of those projects
in the implementation already.
Right?
So, this Launchpad,
are these employees
that can come and say,
I have an idea that I want
to explore within Orbia.
So, I want to take some time
to explore the city.
Because obviously they have a team
that they're working for.
So, how does it actually work?
Because this is where
the constraint is, right?
They have their daily job.
They have their KPIs
that they have to meet.
Yet they're saying,
but I also want to spend
some time innovating.
Yeah. So, the way that it works,
we don't carve out people
out of their day to day.
They need to do it
on top of their day to day.
Okay?
There is a recognition,
there is an understanding,
and there is clarity
from the top management
that once a certain idea move into
what we call funded experiments ,
so, we give them pilot
and we give them money
to experiment. Okay?
Then they can spend, you know,
10, 20% of their time on that.
But all the way through, you know,
developing the idea,
asking what is the problem,
asking what could be the solution,
going through the different stages
of the screening,
it's all on top
of their day to day job.
Right?
But we give them all the coaching.
We teach them about clean start up.
We bring people that can coach
the guys and help them succeed.
So, but it's on top of their day job.
It's not a carve-out activity.
Okay. Okay.
The last piece in the puzzle
is circular economy.
It's a huge domain
and we can talk about it for hours.
But basically
it's how do we become
I mean, Orbia,
how can we become more circular.
How can we make profit, but also do it
in a positive contribution to the planet.
Right?
I love that.
So, it sounds like you're
a venture capitalist.
You're a startup adviser.
You're helping drive
the company forward,
but you're also making the world
a better place.
So, Shai, expect that a lot of people
are going to be very jealous
after they listen to this talk.
But this is extremely inspiring.
And I'm definitely taking
a lot of lessons moving forward
to whatever ventures
I'll start on my own.
But before we go, Shai,
I have to ask you
the most important question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Yeah. Okay.
It's funny because in the process
and it kept me awake
a little bit last night,
you know, the question.
Because it's a good question.
And I also asked my wife,
what does she think.
So, if it's okay with you,
I'll tell you what she said
and I'll tell you what I think.
Okay?
Three words that describe me.
So, she said,
ambitious,
a leader, and high standards.
High standards, it's two words,
but, okay.
There's a hyphen.
Yeah.
And before I asked her,
I thought, you know,
what would I say about myself.
And I said,
curiosity, perseverance and growth.
I love it.
Curiosity, perseverance and growth.
I think that all six words match.
Shai, thank you very, very much.
This is just wonderful.
Thank you for being on the show.
Thank you. Take care.